[Music]
[Applause]
Colorado football is four and five on
the season they lost three straight they
lost to Stanford in overtime UCLA Oregon
State upcoming games host Arizona at
Washington State and then at Utah and
the head coach of the Buffs Deion
Sanders joining us on behalf of C uh
California almonds almonds help with
exercise recovery and uh you can stay in
your uh your Prime coach Prime never
takes a day off which is why he eats
almonds daily to be smart about his
recovery Dion joining us Dion thanks for
joining us how long does a loss stay
with
you oh my God that's the way to come
right at the gate swinging Dan I
wouldn't expect anything less that's why
I love you that's why I love you
um they don't
leave they they they they have their own
little places of solitary confinement
and and they don't leave they don't you
got to understand Dan the reason it's so
tough for
me we hadn't lost a regular season game
in two years at Jackson and before that
it was like three or four straight state
titles in high school so this is
uh mentally it it's not a easy ride but
you know what you signed up for but it
is a roller coaster ride where do you
think you want on that roller coaster
ride well I'm glad you asked because I
just happen to have several statistics
that I showed our team this morning uh
defensive overview we have 18 turnovers
that's tied for fourth in the country we
have eight fbls recovered that's tied
for fourth in the country we have 10
interceptions that's tied for seventh in
the country 23 saes that's tied for 12th
in the country uh 36% Sal rate in the
end zone that's tied for fourth in the
country and compared to to
2022 they only had nine sacks in the
whole season and we have 23 now and
offensively is some of the same thing
like uh 2022 this offense averaged 14.8
points per game now we're averaging 30.7
passing they had uh 1700 yards eight TDS
eight interceptions of course shador
shador 24 touchdown three interceptions
you know average three on 20 yards a
game rushing we're like we're like
luster we we we're not doing anything
but sometimes you got to show these
young men as well as the coaches in the
locker room you got to show them that I
understand we're not where we want to be
but we're trending in the right
direction it's a tremendous amount of
progress and the best thing about
everything Dan is we got a buts kick
once Oregon kicked that flat out butts
we it was no wi when we got out the when
we got out the dur plane it was 30
nothing on the scoreboard that's what we
saw but every other game we've had an
opportunity to to win and we came up
short because we don't know how to win
and we don't have the Personnel yet that
we need to be who we desire to be but
we've had opportunities great
opportunities how frustrating is it when
you played you could control part of
this when you coach you got control but
not player control you are really good
how many years is there for you 40 that
was a that's a great question that
because that's tough and everybody say
are you nervous before the game no I
ain't playing I ain't playing I wish I
could have some type of you know so I am
living by Carly to two guys out there
you know one plays safety and one plays
quarterback so I'm living by Carle to
those guys with Sanders on the back of
the jerseys but you're exactly right you
can't control it things you want to do
things you want to see things that you
know that's going to happen you wish to
God that you had some kind of shoot I
wish it was like Electric football set
that you could just move the men and you
know the but but we don't have that uh
autonomy to do so most parents watch
their kids and they're nervous they're
rooting they're in the stands you're
watching your kids but you're coaching
your kids how different uh not at all
it's all I know I don't know no other
way um Shiloh went to South Carolina so
he got from a of the umbrella for for a
minute for a year a year and a half um
shador only time he ever played without
me was when I was in the hospital with
these blood clots in Jackson so he's
really never played Without Me in his
life so we don't know no other way
that's that's Normy for us from the time
they were coming out the Cradle able to
play um until now and I love it we love
it how long do you celebrate a
win uh right when the last second tis
off the clock I'm on to the
next oh so you don't Savor a victory no
I can't because I'm so it's like you
know shoot David defeated Goliath all
right what's next like let's go I don't
have time to sit up there I I don't I've
never been like that in the NFL college
football now coaching i' I've never been
like that it's it's I'm ready to go to
the next it's I'm a man of challenges I
love challenges my man I I love
challenges so after we've conquered or
after we've conquered I'm on to the next
now when we get conquered that lingers
with you like we we we started off with
that that stays with you because now
you're trying to think about okay I
should have did this I could did that I
could have did that I should have did
that you're thinking about the
idas uh what have you learned about
yourself this
year I need to involve patients with
with some aspects
uh of
coaching in in regards to I want to win
right now and I and I know we can
because I can see it but I do know
where we come up short and I know the
inconsistencies that we have and
sometimes you try to mask it with
certain things but you know deep down
what you need and uh with me man I'm
open book you know I've been shooting
you straight ever since we met so when
I'm sitting in your your Seated on the
couch there I'm gonna always be honest
and sometimes when you're honest you're
too honest for media and they can't
handle everybody's not as poised at you
they don't they they can't see through
the smoke but what I'm telling them the
TR truth you know they think it's a lie
but when I'm telling them really how I
am and how I feel they think more of it
and it's it's instead of just saying R
shoot he's being forthright he's being
straight up but sometimes they're not
used to that kind of honesty and I will
tell you this that I said this when the
season started um that I thought you
were probably seven to 10 players away
that you had topend Talent you didn't
have you didn't have the military on the
ground you needed an army you had some
generals and then you beat TCU and then
I think everybody like It sped up the
process so now you're you're kind of
saying hey the expect did you set the
expectation level maybe too high too
soon no because I've always been
forthright and said okay slow down we
we're not where we're going to be see
they thought I was going to change no
I'm not going to change I'm the same guy
when I lost I'm I'm the same guy I'm I'm
happy I'm excited I'm I'm I'm leading
I'm uh telling you the truth telling you
what's up but but I've also said even
the first time we got our butts kicked I
said hey guys you better get me now we
about eight away eight to 10 guys away
get me now and I was being
honest get your licks now because I know
where we're going I know where we're
headed because I can see I'm at every
practice shoot I I know these kids I I
talk to them I meet with them I I
counsel them I I love them and I know
their shortcomings and I know where
they're strong and I know where they're
weak as as well as the coaching staff
like I know these men that we've
gathered together to call coaches I know
what we have in the house while we're
being honest I critiqued you when you
came in and you got rid of those kids at
Colorado but the video and I I don't
mind that you do it because it's a
business but the video went viral and I
felt bad for those kids so just want to
I don't know I don't know why let me
tell you this because this is something
you may not know maybe 20 kids we may
have sat down with and said you know we
may head in a different direction I
don't know if this going to work out
everybody else quit
Dan they quit like I can't be you can't
hold me responsible and some guys you
attributed to us they would even on the
roster I remember one kid made a big
deal out of uh he couldn't get his film
we wasn't
here for the walk on tap that you wanted
we weren even here we weren't even a
part of the program why would they quit
your
program because when you see if I go out
there and I see Jordan and and the Dream
Team practice it and I'm sitting up
there saying I don't know if this gonna
work out for me I know play uh know if I
could play for God bless the late great
bob Knight he's he's he's a little too
animated than fourth coming I don't know
if I could do that and they want to play
football so
now kids don't tough it out they shut it
down that's why we created the portal
isn't it so they could get another
option to go and do what they really
want to do and play like they desired to
play so that happened we had kids when
we had the dur spring game everybody but
three defensive linemen quit that week
up like it was going to hurt us and we
like so I mean that that's truly what
happened so we got accredited for a lot
of kids that we shouldn't have got
accredited for he's Deon he's Deion
Sanders joining us on behalf of
California almonds coach Prime never
takes a day off which is why he eats
almonds daily to be smart about his
recovery what makes for a good pitch
man honesty sincerity
passion honesty sincerity passion like I
really eat almonds like I really eat KFC
I I I you know some the things I endorse
I really do it's not just hey let me
line myself up with this company no no I
really do this stuff so the authenticity
I think you can see it bleed through the
TV or the uh or when it doesn't you you
can say hey man come on man be for real
who do you think's the best pitch man
that have you taken any advice or you
watch somebody and say oh you know what
I'm going to sell something like that no
I I haven't because we've been at this
for a long time it's it's sort of like
this is the third quarter of life you
know you had that first came out of
college you had prime time then you then
you went to Prime now it's coach Prime
this is like the third quarter like
we're still going and we winning how
would you have done an nil oh my God
that would have been spectacular because
people get misconstrued with Nils and
collectives most people
are boasting with collectives when when
you know alumni put a bunch of money in
the party and give to the kids you only
see maybe several kids in the whole
country with nil deals I mean that's the
truth that they're endorsable it's hard
for a business or CEO to say I'm gonna
put this much money on a kid we don't
know if the kid drinks smokes we don't
know what he he gonna get into with his
girlfriend you don't know you you really
want to take that risk as a CEO so you
want to let that kid get into the
college and develop a little bit first
so you really get to know him a bit so
that's an nil and we just happen to have
two of the leading nil earners in
college fo football with Travis Hunter
and shador what car would you have been
driving in Florida
State I probably would had a driver
let's just get
this you had a chauffeur yeah i' i' had
a driver yeah let's let's let's make
sure we get that straight I'd had a
driver for sure you love your goals you
have goals you have goals that you set
but um is the NFL a goal eventually in
your life
coaching yeah no no not whatsoever I
don't think I'm built for the
NFL I I I don't think because I'm too I
appreciate the game so much and I
respect the game so much of what the
game is consistently done for me for a
multitude of years that when I see a guy
getting paid millions and million
millions of dollars and he has no
respect for the game does not want to
Excel and exceed expectations of the
game I'm GNA have a true problem so I'm
the kind of coach that would go out
there with 53 and come back after
halftime with about
32 because I can't do it like I'm I'm
too brutally honest and I want to win
that much and I I need everybody that
respects the game and oftentimes money
clouds that judgment that is is
happening in college football money
clouds that that love and that passion
for the gay what if it's a packaged deal
with you and
shador um don't forget charow by the way
don't forget sh eventually eventually
he's coming yeah they're going to come
out the same year next year okay they
better not try to leave daddy this year
by the
way I I I don't know I don't know I I
haven't thought man I'm trying to win a
game I'm not thinking down the street
that far I haven't thought thought like
that that's a great thought process
though what was going through your mind
when you're in hospital having surgery
uh
thank you Lord It's hard to Fathom but
I'm serious Dan it was thank you Lord
that you chose me because I don't know a
lot of people that can deal with this I
think I had nine surgeries in a matter
of days you know like like it was cut
and dried if I'm if I'm gonna make it
then okay if I'm gonna have my leg okay
and now if I'm gonna have my foot so all
those different things was going through
your mind and you want to make sure okay
did I give enough love to my kids or you
know to my mother and my sister like
like you think about all those different
things I just remember when you showed
us your toes when you we were in Houston
and you took off your shoes sock yeah
that yeah that's when I had all of them
I was yeah yeah that was tough having
lunch that day after seeing
that that was tough I was like I think I
don't know what we had for lunch but it
reminded me of your foot and I
go that was
nasty but it's so funny that you know
the blood clots it was hereditary and uh
just sometimes I look down now like Lord
thank you like I I I never said why me
never question God never question the
path never anything I knew it was going
to be something tremendous on the other
end and now I'm living it okay how fast
could you run the right now
um I could beat probably three quarters
of my
friends and they have all their toes
they have
all hey great to connect with you again
uh good luck the uh rest of the season
here uh thanks for joining us and how
tell me again how long has it been
because you you're a legend I've been
doing it 40 years wow yeah 40 years that
is awesome but you know I set out to
have a long shelf life I I wanted to
make sure I did it right and continue to
do it that
way well I appreciate that distinguished
voice and your honesty your integrity
just how you've always treated me man I
got love for you man you're a good dude
one good appreciate you thank you that's
Dion Sanders uh joining us on behalf of
California almonds coach Prime never
takes a day off which is why he eats
Almond's daily to be smart about his
recovery